un nouveau rassemblement anti à nikol
pashinian qui s'est achevée vers 18h30
heure locale
ici devant le parlement une mobilisation
qui a été plutôt festive puisque une
scène a été montée
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
où plusieurs prises de parole en public
se sont succédé des concerts également
de personnalités un public venu soutenir
ce mouvement anti à nikol pashinian en
tout cas vous le voyez aussi certaines
tentes ont été construites ici un devant
le parlement des tentes qui abrite
certains manifestants qui sont là à
depuis jeudi qui dorment dans ces tentes
afin de maintenir à cette contestation
populaire à des tentes rouges également
que vous pouvez apercevoir où des mets
culinaires issus du haut karabagh sont
donnés gratuitement aux manifestants
chaque jour afin de contester un contre
le pouvoir de nikol pashinian jugé
responsable de la défaite militaire dans
cette région
une défaite militaire est vécu comme une
humiliation nationale par certains
manifestants
je vous propose d'en écouter quelques
uns ce sujet nous venons ici chaque jour
avec un seul objectif nous devons nous
débarrasser du traître nikol pashinian
au plus tôt c'est notre but
il a vendu notre pays ici se rassemblent
des gens qui ont mal pour leur patrie
qui sont prêts jour et nuit
malgré la neige et le froid à exprimer
leur désaccord avec ce qu'il s'est passé
et se passe encore dans notre pays nous
sommes proches de la victoire
nous en sommes sûrs aujourd'hui ou
demain il ne sera plus au pouvoir
je m'attends à ce qu'il y ait plus de
manifestations qu'auparavant car les
gens ont commencé à comprendre qu'il y a
eu une trahison global commises par
l'homme qui occupe maintenant le poste
de premier ministre est notre seule
exigence et qu'il quitte ce poste au
chaud nikol pashinian qui arrêtait sa
demande de révocation du chef d'état
major de l'armée il a également appelé à
tous ses partisans à se réunir demain à
18h30 place de la république non loin
adieu parlement pour pouvoir poursuivre
le combat pour l'armée lit elle mais il
a également appelé au calme pour éviter
tout affrontement à civile demain entre
les deux camps écouter me choque pas que
comme jelly le ring
certains représentants des forces
politiques seront invités à participer à
la manifestation
nous leur proposerons également de
prendre la parole lors de la
manifestation pour que celle de demain
servent dans le fond les deux objectifs
que j'ai mentionné un corps ou gère tout
le premier objectif
je le répète est de montrer qu'en
république d'arménie
il y à une société forte une société qui
peuvent former et protéger son pouvoir
je parle bien de la société pas du
gouvernement
le second objectif est de montrer qu'en
arménie
la page des affrontements civile du 1er
mars est tournée je veux dire qu'il
était exclu que ce genre de situation se
reproduise
et nous pouvons tous ensemble être
garant de ce processus avant tout le
gouvernement bien sûr mais aussi la
société cette mobilisation qui s'est
achevée vers 18h30 je vous le disais
elle s'est déroulée dans le calme et a
globalement ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
malgré quelques tensions quelques
débordements et des images violentes
globalement les forces de l'ordre
contrôlant ce soulèvement populaire un
important dispositif de sécurité a été
mis en place tout autour du parlement ce
qui devrait être le cas demain également
place de la république est ici juste
devant le parlement arménien